he's not even three days old and yet
life is already stacked against him
like all the other babies here he will
have no birth certificate and no
citizenship the mothers looked dazed
almost absent the fan does little to
ease the stifling humidity but the fact
that these rahaga mothers have come to
deliver their babies in one of the camps
clinics is a small victory the main
challenges is that they don't come to us
in there are early pregnancies and they
feel any complication then they come
before Congress and they basically don't
come to us the majority of women here
are giving birth in their bamboo huts
often with the help of a rahaga midwife
it is their traditional way that's what
Bashara did at 29 years old this is her
eighth child by Stover certified it it I
think wasn't like I was in a lot of pain
while giving birth it took all night my
child was born at dawn I wasn't able to
go to any clinic I didn't have their
number also I couldn't walk so how could
I get there there is little chance of
getting to a clinic here at night the
camp is unlit and you have to navigate
narrow alleyways before you get to any
kind of main road it's worrying the
health workers here I'm hi Xena kabul
state hockey
they live in very unhygienic conditions
and don't come for health check-ups even
if we try to convince them that's why
infections spread and leads to infants
developing a lot of complications
mother's end up developing eclampsia and
pregnancy-induced hypertension and
diabetes aside from the health risks it
also means a growing population a
growing refugee population the
Bangladesh says it won't host forever
and Myanmar clearly doesn't want back
more than 100 babies are born into these
camps every day now that amounts to
around 35,000 new lives every year more
than half of Bangladesh's rahaga
population are children it does make you
question what kind of future do they
face there are basic learning centers
here for the younger ones but no formal
education and for the teenagers there is
much to do there is no education for
them and they can't leave the camp to
find jobs spending time here
it really is striking how many children
there are lives on hold before they've
even begun Stephanie Decker al-jazeera
Kuta belong camp southeastern Bangladesh